Speaker 1: One other Russia Ukraine story I want
to mention this made big headlines over the last
24 hours, and the headline is Russian airstrike
has hit a Ukrainian maternity hospital. The
Associated Press is reporting a Russian airstrike
devastated a maternity hospital Wednesday
in the besieged port city of Mariupol amid growing
warnings from the West that Moscow's invasion is
about to take a more brutal and indiscriminate
turn. Ukrainian officials said the attack wounded
at least 17 people. The ground shook more than
a mile away when the Mariupol complex was hit
by a series of blasts that blew out windows and
ripped away much of the front of one building.
Vladimir Nicolin, a top regional police official
standing in the ruins, said today Russia committed
a huge crime. It is a war crime without any
justification. This story alone is generating a
ton of discussion about what is the truth here. On
the one hand, there was the reaction that Russia
is now deliberately bombing maternity hospitals,
and we saw the head of the airstrike against an
orphanage last week and against the Children's
Hospital last week. So one perspective is they're
doing this on purpose to wreak havoc and cause
terror. The counterpoint was it is of no advantage
whatsoever to Putin to deliberately strike a
maternity hospital. What would be the point?
Obviously, Russia doesn't think that pregnant
mothers and health care workers and newborn babies
are the ones waging the war against them, so they
would never deliberately hit a maternity hospital.
If they did, it must be indifference or lack
of precision. However, the latest that I've
read is Russia is claiming that the maternity
ward was being used as a state, as a staging
area for Ukrainian troops and volunteers, et
cetera, and that there were not actually any
pregnant women in the maternity ward at the time,
and that when Ukraine says our maternity ward was
hit, that it's merely propaganda because everybody
knows that it's actually a military staging area.
Do we ultimately know the truth? Maybe,
maybe. I certainly don't know it right now,
and I'm open to it being any of the above
that I just mentioned. But I think the most
important takeaway from individual stories like
this are that it is complete and total. Chaos
and that this is still an optional invasion
by Russia, and so it's very easy, you know,
I look at these discussions that happen online and
people are getting extraordinarily flustered and
angry with each other and adversarial over. No,
no, no. This was obviously deliberate. No, no,
no. Obviously, Russia would never deliberately
hit a maternity ward. It goes against their
strategic objectives and it goes against their
PR objectives as well. I don't think we know. And
one of the things that we are seeing is when
folks get involved in the minutia and I'm
not saying we don't care whether a maternity
ward was hit. Obviously, we do. And obviously,
people are getting wounded and people are
dying, and 17 wounded is supposedly the number
from this particular incident. When you get
bogged down in the details, the point is you
end up fighting with people assuming that their
good faith actor is now if they're just, you know,
Russian trolls pro Russian trolls, OK, then
then it's that that's a different story. But
when you get bogged down in the in the
specifics of what happened in this one incident,
it's very easy to lose the main thread,
which is this is an optional, premeditated
invasion of aggression of Ukraine by Russia.
And when we end up arguing with people about why
would would Russia deliberately do this
if they knew that there were not actually
Ukrainian troops there or if they did, or if we
end up missing that big picture? And that's the
big picture that we have to remember. And quite
frankly, going back to the previous segment, I did
that big picture of an optional premeditated
invasion of aggression by Russia to try to take
land or to install a puppet government.
Whatever, ultimately, is Putin's goal.
That's the big picture that has united the West
and American allies and Naito allies. And so
we want to know what happened here. We do. And it
matters what happened here. It doesn't change the
big picture of what's going on in the region,
and I think that's the important takeaway.
Let me know your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at Packman.